before we begin
it's important that i emphasize a few
disclaimers
by no means am i calling the individuals
mentioned in this video
scammers consider what you are about to
see
a criticism of their business practices
and promoted
ideologies not an incitement of
harassment or hate
i have no way of knowing their true
intentions
it is entirely possible that those
mentioned have created their teachings
with good intent
no matter how misguided those teachings
have become and whilst i will be
including sources to back up every claim
that i make
treat this video as my own opinion and
conclusions surrounding the subject of
new age spirituality
and new thoughts related ideas now
to those who think i am criticizing
anyone who is trying to make money
you have misunderstood my position one
look at my channel will show you
i have no problem with somebody making
money
however i do take issue with the context
surrounding how they make their money a
lot of people actually were in my group
were attending the events the courses
you know hope to make money so that they
could feed the family but
you know unfortunately i've lost it new
age spirituality has seen
incredible growth in the mainstream
having a huge
influence on the self-help industry
thanks to figures like napoleon hill
rhonda byrne and others who i will be
discussing further but what seemingly
goes
unnoticed is the booming business behind
it that i think
does more harm than good when you
recognize your vibrational frequency
you're drawing into yourself all the
time
literally the vibration that is most
like what you're
putting out right there was a woman who
had cancer
who refused medical treatment because
she believed in the secret in this video
we'll take a look at some of its most
influential figures its roots and how it
is fundamentally
built from a flawed and dangerous
disregard for reality
now it would be impossible for me to
cover the entirety of the new thought
movement
in just one video so bear in mind that
there will be influential figures in
this industry that i fail to mention or
decide
to cut however i want you to take notice
of the patterns
from multi-level marketing to scammers
to self-help to pseudoscience
to subtle deception i'll aim to
demonstrate why i think
new age spirituality has inherently
allowed itself to become
the perfect grift
[Music]
hey how's everybody doing today me too
all right here's what i want to talk
about today working in an office
it's class exclusive all-wheel drive a
premium navigation
this low everyday price is here to stay
we'll get you approved in 30 minutes or
less i guarantee it
did i know at the time out of my
greatest despair
was to come the greatest gift
i couldn't believe all the people who
knew this
they were the greatest people in history
i began searching for people alive today
who know the secret you know this secret
gives you everything you want in 2006
ronda byrne released her film the secret
a film that promised to change your life
featuring various
gurus who promoted an idea that could
bring you health
wealth and happiness that idea was the
law
of attraction everything that's coming
into your life you are attracting into
your life
and it's attracted to you by virtue of
the images you're holding in your mind
a film that suggested being overweight
came from thinking
fat thoughts or that the only reason a
person does not have enough money
is because they are blocking money from
coming to them with their own
thoughts the secret is the law of
attraction it was a feel-good
message the film exceeded 65 million
dollars in sales
and became something of a cultural
phenomenon have you heard about it
this is the secret talk about this dvd
has been spreading
around the world i i had friends that
were telling me
that the secret is real girl i knew sent
me a book
[Music]
called the secret she was like listen
david this is gonna help these
but what you are also witnessing here is
the success
of another kind a success at rebranding
an idea that had been cultivated for
many years before burns film
fast forward to present day and you'll
find no shortage of gurus promoting
these same
rehash ideas the moment you start
feeling abundant and worthy you are
generating wealth
three law of attraction truths that i
wish
i knew earlier whatever you can see in
your mind
you can hold in your hand whether you
want to be a millionaire with seven
steps to speed up the law of attraction
using your spiritual powers here we
establish
the first pattern of this industry
targeting
a vulnerable audience those who are
struggling financially having
relationship problems
or suffering from a disease are
particularly favorable
or perhaps you're just searching for
answers
this idea this law of attraction
seems to serve up answers in such a
simple yet idealistic
way and the truth is you can actually
get whatever you want in life whatever
you can see in your mind
you can hold in your hand whether you
want to be a millionaire whether you
want to give you
three ways to manifest money within 24
hours
do you like to get your ex back the law
of attraction
may be the power you need when you're
vulnerable or desperate
critical thinking is dull and feeling an
emotion
cloud your decision-making abilities so
when you're presented this
secret a secret that promises to change
your life with so little effort
who could possibly fault you for wanting
to believe
the bait has been set but you have to
understand
the law of attraction is only one branch
of a bigger
belief system to understand the problems
with the ideas ronda presented
you have to examine the roots of where
it all began
from here you can trace the same
patterns and the influence it's having
over the gurus we see
today
the new thought movement was centered
around a few
key ideas that we and everything in
existence
are essentially god or at least we all
have some level of divinity within us
positive thinking has the power to carry
forth manifestations into the material
world
new thoughts supposed origins travel
back to a man named phineas parkhurst
quimby
an american clockmaker born in 1802.
quimby became interested in the idea of
using the mind as a way of curing people
from illness and disease
after he himself had supposedly
recovered from tuberculosis
through his own healing methods his
philosophy became the basis for new
thought
quimby's teachings inspired many other
authors
and so-called philosophers to continue
spreading and expanding on his message
and the overall new thoughts movement in
those years
new thoughts focused on our mind's
ability to heal us from illness and
disease
it emphasized intuition feeling and
anecdotal evidence
rather than empirical science-based
evidence
it wasn't however until the 20th century
where the new thought movement
extrapolated this into wealth creation
the ideology is perfect if our thoughts
had the power to quite
literally change the material world
surely they could manifest wealth
too then a man named napoleon hill
came right out of the blue with his
first book the law of success
and a decade later his best-selling book
think and grow rich
up to this point it's nigh impossible to
tell what the intentions of most new
thought authors were
the ideas they presented in their works
were logically flawed in many
areas some of which i have already
discussed in the first installment of
this series
others of which we will get into soon
but it's when we get to figures like
napoleon hill that the lines between
good intentions
and con artistry are blurred because
hill had an
immense influence over many of the new
thought law of attraction gurus that
have come
since having had his works promoted and
circulated
in countless business and self-help
circles i promise you
if you yourself haven't heard of this
book you know someone who has
but my question to you now is how much
do you really know
about napoleon hill because if we take a
dive into hill's past
we notice that the reputation he's
acquired amongst the new thought
movement
is not at all what it seems on the
contrary his true narrative is one of
failed businesses
fraud and grossly exaggerated
achievements
think and grow rich echoes much of the
new thought sentiment
especially when it comes to the pursuit
of riches highlighting how
our thoughts and our desires can be
transmuted into their financial
equivalent
hill even goes as far as to use examples
in which
thoughts have been able to cure deafness
including his own sons
this is a book that napoleon claims he
was tasked with creating
after meeting one of the richest men in
the world at the time
andrew carnegie whereby carnegie tasked
him to interview some of the most
successful men in business
and learn the secrets to their success
but go
a little further down that rabbit hole
and you'll realize
hill may not be the person he is so
commonly portrayed as by his fans
or his own works in 1907
30 years before the release of think and
grow rich hill co-founded the acree hill
lumber company in mobile alabama only a
year later
the pensacola journal reported that the
company was liable to bankruptcy
proceedings and charges of mail fraud
it turns out that hill had bought lumber
from outside of mobile on credit
before selling the lumber at a much
lower price in cash
eventually creditors and other
businesses were catching wind of the
fraud and in september of 1908
hill was on the run from authorities it
was around this time that napoleon hill
claimed he spoke with andrew carnegie
but
according to andrew carnegie's
biographer there was quote
no evidence of any sort that carnegie
and hill
ever met in 1909 hill initiated the
automobile college of washington
a college that promised students to
teach them how to build
shaw fur and sell motor cars only it
turns out this college
was just a way of getting free labor for
building cars and then selling them
the motorworld magazine in april 1912
called hills college a scam and a quote
joked to anyone of average intelligence
listing the many insane claims that
hills college had been making
along with its scheme of paying students
three dollars ahead per any other
student they had recruited into the
college
much akin to a multi-level marketing
scheme we might see today
the college eventually folded in 1912
but hill wasn't finished trying to make
a name for himself
and in 1915 he established a school
called
the george washington institute of
advertising intending to teach the
principles of success and
self-confidence
only three years later two warrants had
been issued for the arrest of hill with
charges of violating blue sky laws
you see hill established the college
with a 100 000
capitalization and attempted to sell the
shares to investors
primarily his own students despite the
school's assets being worth at best
twelve hundred dollars the school ended
not long afterwards
and this only scratches the surface of
the other swindles hill had been
involved in
of course i understand what the common
rebuke here would be
napoleon hill's book actually has value
and i myself have taken value from that
book
why should i care if the man himself had
a fraudulent past
but that's the point isn't it if you
were
a grifter then for the grift to work you
must be able to provide
some crumb of truth the strategy is
simple yet so effective
gain the trust of your victim by
preaching some level of truth
then subtly attach more extreme ideas to
that truth
until the victim can no longer recognize
the difference
new thought does this constantly
positive thinking
is no longer just a tool solely for
better day-to-day well-being
it becomes a powerful force that can
literally manifest material results
health and disease according to new
thoughts can be cured
simply through the power of our minds
consider this
how many people have read and engrossed
themselves in the teachings of napoleon
hill
hundreds if not millions of individuals
but how many of them
truly managed to achieve the financial
success that they initially visualized
on being tasked to do so when reading
the book
most i'd wager have likely not why is
that
because financial success can't possibly
be reduced down to your thinking
or your ability to visualize wealth even
taking action
which hill admittedly does promote in
his book is no guarantee for financial
success
action increases probabilities but for
this to be a law
it must work every time and yet new
thought is fundamentally
unfalsifiable we can't measure thoughts
and feelings
nor the supposed vibrations thoughts and
feelings have
and that's just the thing see the best
grift is the one that leaves the grifter
blameless anyone right now can write a
book or sell a program
on the law of attraction they can run
ads targeting vulnerable consumers
and best of all if their teachings don't
work the blame
never falls on them it's always your
fault
you didn't believe enough you weren't
thinking positive enough you had
resistance you weren't patient enough
now the price of a book
doesn't seem daunting if you only spend
a few dollars and glean some value from
it then it seems rather harmless
and possibly worth the money but how
would you feel if the price of said book
was a figure much higher than just
a few dollars how would you feel about
someone promoting a
secret or guarantee of success for much
larger amounts of money
napoleon hill's book has been an
inspiration to many
as the new thought movement continues to
grow inspiring much of the self-help
industry we're consumed by today
two of which went by the names of jerry
and esther
hicks we'd like to ask abraham to come
and speak to us okay
it just takes a few seconds
it is nice to have an opportunity to
visit
[Music]
esther hicks claims that she can channel
an entity or rather a group of entities
known as abraham hicks charging hundreds
of dollars for their seminars and
workshops
good morning
members of the audience are invited
forward to pose a question to esther
or more specifically the abraham entity
she is supposedly
channeling hi it's nice to see you again
thank you again
and thank you to esther
whilst jerry sits at the side somewhere
taking notes
perhaps for their next book we want to
say that in this
book that is coming there are 33
examples of all kinds of things that
might happen in someone's life
and each of these exams both esther and
jerry have authored countless books
promoting the teachings of this abraham
entity
which are structured like a conversation
between jerry and abraham
with the latter giving answers to life's
most asked questions
esther goes as far as claiming on her
site that this is the original source
material
for the current law of attraction in
fact
many in the law of attraction community
suggests that ronda burns film
the secret was just a watered-down
version of hicks's teachings
and it's precisely because of esther's
reputation as the
most authentic one out of the two that i
think it's worth discussing her
because upon closer inspection we see
that much of hicks's teachings
are exactly what we've come to
understand from new thought
i don't actually have to know whether or
not esther really is channeling an
entity for me to be extremely skeptical
of her work
the contradictions and problematic
teachings speak far more to her
legitimacy
than any claims of channeling in
esther's book
the law of attraction one such
problematic teaching
centers around the idea that a victim of
a robbery is a co-creator of the
violence inflicted upon them
jerry states i can understand robbers
being attracted to those they're robbing
but it's difficult to see
innocent victims attracting the robbery
or the person being discriminated
against attracting the prejudice
hicks responds they are just the same
the assaulted
and the assaulter are co-creators of the
event
if you think hicks's response here is a
one-off
you'd be mistaken she emphasizes this
point
numerous times take a moment to truly
consider
the level of victim blaming and lack of
accountability
that such a position would lead to or
instead of a robbery
imagine a child born into poverty who
starves to death
before the age of five according to
hicks's teachings
these children were co-creators of their
fate
and this isn't a belief shared just by
hicks alone
this is a fundamental premise in all of
new thoughts
by this logic we can say that the
perpetrators of countless crimes
shouldn't be held accountable
after all they are just the product of
their victim's vibrational frequency
any rational person can see the danger
of this thinking
but as we've come to learn for the
preacher of such ideas
this logic is perfect because all who
complain that they haven't been able to
manifest health
wealth abundance or whatever dream we've
sold them on
we can tell these people that it isn't
the fault of our belief system that they
didn't get what they wanted
it is in fact their fault and as we
pedal more of our workshops write more
of our books
we have an excuse each and every time
someone attempts to challenge our ideas
so
what we notice as we look into the
medical profession today
we see doctors and scientists literally
scaring
people to death with their
pronouncements of diseases that are
incurable
when we know that there is not any
disease that is incurable
you can get to where you want to be from
wherever you are
if you will point in the direction that
you want to go and continue to move in
that direction
esther hicks as we've already discovered
with others in the new thought movement
makes the claim that our thoughts and
feelings or our vibrational frequencies
can cure us of any disease
it seems odd then or rather hypocritical
that her husband
jerry himself passed away from cancer in
2011
but this hypocrisy is something we'll
see more of as we continue
now you might ask why bother adding all
the metaphysical and pseudo-scientific
ideas in the first place
if esther and jerry were truly trying to
con people or just make a ton of money
wouldn't it have appealed to a bigger
market if she simply passed herself
off as a life coach rather than turning
potential customers off of her works by
claiming that she could
channel another entity i however
disagree it's my opinion that the
addition of spirituality and channeling
is actually an incredibly clever
marketing device
because now life advice turns into
the teachings of abraham and if one
wants to hear the teachings of abraham
they must go to the source they must go
to the person who is claiming to channel
this divine entity
this creates scarcity around hicks's
business of answering humanity's burning
questions
and the scarce of the product the more
valuable it becomes
so when you're given an eye-watering
price tag no one bats an eyelid
it is my opinion that new thoughts use
of spirituality and pseudoscience
serves this exact purpose allowing your
teachings to seem more valuable in the
marketplace
it is my opinion that the use of an
abraham entity is more of a marketing
device than anything else
conceived from the foundation of jerry
hicks's past career
as a high-level distributor for the
multi-level marketing company
amway a company that preached ideas like
the law of attraction
and books like napoleon hills think and
grow rich because they recognized that
in order to keep members inside the mlm
scheme
they had to blame themselves if they
didn't achieve the goals the mlm
promised
either way none of this stopped oprah
from inviting esther for an interview
years later
just as she had done with ronda burns
and that for over 20 years
esther hicks and her husband jerry have
been spreading the word of that
so-called secret
it didn't stop the abraham hicks
money-making machine from running as
usual
the secret just like esther and jerry's
works well repackaged ideas from the
same route
new thought it was perfect to promise
you
health wealth love and abundance all in
one go
to package it all under an umbrella of
spirituality
believe that once you discover the
secret
that you can immediately start creating
the life you want
whether it's getting out of debt whether
it's finding a more fulfilling job
even falling in love ronda's film earned
her millions
and it gave an incredible boost to the
careers of the supposed teachers it
featured
allowing them to branch away from the
franchise to run their own coaching
businesses
and cash in on spiritual retreats but i
remind you
new thoughts is a belief system
perfectly designed for grifters who
don't care for the desperately ill
poor and helpless who line their pockets
leading them to push
incredibly dangerous ideas onto their
victims
so what if i just visualize checks
coming in the mail so i'll just
visualize
a bunch of checks coming in tomorrow
within just one month
things start to change and it's amazing
today i just get
checks in the mail i get a few bills but
i get more checks than bills
but now serious questions have been
raised about his business dealings
in this exclusive investigation ben
fordham has found investors left high
and dry
and demanding justice a former student
of sherman's who spent
thirty thousand dollars to learn about
the stock market
part of the the funds were supposed to
be put into a trading fund
and david would then try those funds on
this on the futures stock market
what happened to that fund well we don't
know it's their money
they paid you the tuition fees it's not
there and you told them that you would
take five thousand dollars out of each
person's tuition
and trade it on the market and they
would receive 50 of the profits
they never received any profits where's
the money
that money it and come back to the
original question
is the money
please answer the question
the money and as i someone asked me
recently the same question
is the money david please answer the
question
where is the money where is the money
you tell me
most people look at their current state
of affairs and they say this is who i am
that's not who you are that's who you
were
and so you must continually invest in
yourself you've got to grow
in every single way your money is
nothing more
than the amount of energy paper energy
that you have in your pocket or purse
yeah what's the problem two people
aren't breathing
towards no pulse police are focusing
their investigation on james arthur ray
the motivational speaker and self-help
guru who ran the five-day retreat
over 60 people were in the sweat lodge
for two hours as the culmination of
rey's spiritual warrior retreat
it was pitch black inside and extremely
hot
when it was over two people were dead
ended while she was trying to improve it
that's when she found self-help guru
james arthur wray
i can help you i really can the
motivational speaker had already built a
multi-million dollar business
launched by the popular movie the secret
she reached one of the highest level
workshops
a retreat which cost her her life
savings
ten thousand dollars do find the
defendant james arthur wray on the
offense of negligent homicide
as a result of the death of kirby brown
as follows guilty
on november 23rd i was diagnosed with
breast cancer
i truly believed in my heart with my
strong faith that i was already healed
i saw myself as if cancer was never in
my body from the time i was diagnosed
which was november 23rd
to the time i was healed totally
was approximately three months and
that's without radiation and
chemotherapy
[Music]
you will attract everything that you
require if it's money you need you'll
attract if it's people you need you'll
attraction if it's a certain book you
need you're attracted
bob proctor is a preacher of the law of
attraction
appearing numerous times during rhonda
burns film
but perhaps you may not know bob proctor
had also been a
big promoter of the multi-level
marketing company
vemma a company that specifically
targeted
universities aiming to find teenagers
and young adults who are filled with
dreams of wealth and fame
here you create your own income you can
be 16 to make as much money as you want
you can be 85 make as much money as you
want why would you let somebody else
tell you how much money you're worth
that doesn't make sense to me
bob proctor made several appearances at
their events
as his books were promoted amongst
vemma's young distributors
in fact i introduced my own wife to the
company and she earns
tens of thousands of dollars now now i
recommended that she join a company
called vemma and i recommended it
because i know the man that owns the
company
and there's a company i'm working with
vemma and i'm working with their people
worldwide because i'm going to tell you
this is one of the best opportunities
for time
and money freedom that you're ever going
to find the opportunity that you're
looking at here with vemma
we'll give you that and charles was
going to explain an idea
about vemma about what a phenomenal
product it is
but what a phenomenal compensation plan
now i've got a reputation that is
worldwide
i wouldn't do anything to stain or do
hurt my reputation
in 2015 the company was shut down for
essentially being a pyramid scheme
alex morton one of the figureheads for
vemma later went on to promoting a
similar multi-level marketing scheme
my name is alex morton and i'm the
executive vice president
of i markets live now who
else do you think promotes imarkets live
attending and speaking at their
conferences
[Music]
i believe that's the goal of all
thinking people
that join the i am academy there's such
a phenomenal opportunity here
but of course this is no issue to bob
proctor
as he can continue promoting these
schemes whilst charging for his own
self-help courses and programs you are
all and i am god's highest form of
creation
one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
attention for all of you wondering the
simplest way
to sum up the law of attraction get rich
using the law of attraction on the 17
second manifestation you expand your
awareness
favorite law of attraction and
manifesting acts so it's just one
payment of 3.99
or three installments at 149. how to
manifest a text from a specific
person and how to manifest your
significant other
manifesting health for the people in our
life you want to manifest anything you
want into your life
ask for a video on how to manifest
someone attract your twin
flame money money scarcity manifestation
to some it'll be nothing but a passing
fad
to others in a more vulnerable and
desperate situation
it'll be their last perceived lifeline a
ticket to escaping debt
a ticket to repairing relationships a
ticket to curing themselves of a disease
and we'll see the same pattern repeat
itself again
and again of those searching for
miracles and those
selling them because i know i was
absolutely broken
and it's the only way i could put it in
the world i was broken because of my
experience
how much money did you lose in your
experience
all in all the cost of ten thousand
pounds
i know it's a sick
and as a single parent that's got to be
devastating um devastating
is a bit of an understatement
what is the law of attraction or new
thought when you realize that positive
thinking
visualizations meditation affirmations
are all
tools that exist separately from this
belief system
when we strip away all these tools from
new thought then perhaps you'll see it
in a truer light
an unhealthy glorification of positivity
with a lack of care for real science
opting instead for anecdotes and
unfalsifiable claims
of course science isn't able to explain
everything yet
the problem of consciousness is a real
one but when i look at new thoughts or
new age spirituality in general
it doesn't seem truly interested in
these ideas
it instead uses spirituality to promote
great dreams and a feel-good message
that dumbs down complicated issues like
obtaining wealth
or disease into metaphysical
pseudo-scientific
concepts it uses spirituality to avoid
harsher realities about the world at
large it is guilty of the just world
fallacy
assuming that positive actions will lead
to positive consequences
completely ignoring the fact that
sometimes those who are optimistic
and positive all their lives can be run
down and taken advantage of
whilst other individuals who are morally
bankrupt advance successfully in their
careers with no repercussions
it's easy to fall into new thoughts
overly optimistic and naive painting of
reality
i know this because i myself have done
so in a video on this very channel i
promoted the works of eckhart tolle
and although tolle's books steer more
towards eastern and taoist philosophy
i didn't realize that what i was
promoting was still a gateway into new
thought
my message here is not that you should
abandon your goals visions or dreams
but that you should be wary of an
industry that uses
unfalsifiable claims and an unimaginable
amount of pseudoscience to generate
millions in revenue critical thinking is
a skill and it should be
honed and practiced from looking at the
new thought movement's tendency to
attract those who have
questionable intentions to its
incredibly harmful claims about health
and medicine
and its constant habit of victim blaming
it should be met with extreme scrutiny
and a series like this isn't going to
stop this ever-growing industry
but my hope is that it gets you to see
another side to this belief system
whether you yourself believe in it or
whether you know someone who does
because at some point i'm certain you
will encounter
new thoughts or new age spirituality
whether it be on the train home from
work
whilst talking to a friend or scrolling
through your social media feed
if this series gets you to do anything
in that moment
it's this to stop and think critically
no matter how vulnerable your situation
to not let someone bypass your reason
and logic
to be able to spot when someone is
promising you a dream
to spot when someone is presenting you a
crumb of truth so that you accept their
larger more extreme claims as truth too
to spot all of this and to be able to
see through the illusion
an illusion masquerading as truth using
pseudoscience
spirituality and a feel-good message as
bait
and that my friends brings us to the end
of this video and series
before you click off if you haven't
already seen it part one will be linked
in the description below it goes without
saying again that this isn't about
inciting harassment or hate it is about
my thoughts and critique on new age
spirituality and the new thought
movement i'm sure there's gonna be a lot
of heated debates in the comments below
which i look forward to
reading but uh if you did enjoy this
video in this series
do hit the like button do subscribe to
the channel if you like the content
those things are free but they really do
help out
with everything that i'm doing with the
channel and if you'd like to support the
channel further i've got a patreon where
i do q and a's video editing tutorials
that kind of thing so
if that sounds like something you might
be interested in do check it out link
will be in the description below but
look
with all of those call to actions out of
the way um
thank you to you the watcher who has
watched through to the end
i can't emphasize enough how much that
that that really does mean a lot
especially
for huge projects like this i hope to
see you in the future videos coming up
again a lot of exciting projects to work
on my friends i hope you have a
wonderful rest of the day
as always hunter head salute
too many days is yet to come
too many times has come to
pass
too many moments put aside
getting out alive
getting out of line
writing letters in the sand
[Music]
lost